[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today is a very special day
and this is a very special video because
we are finally going to go over all nine
Titan shifters their powers and users
past and present as I write this it was
only yesterday that the identity and
powers of the Warhammer Titan were
revealed in the newest manga chapter
it's finally here and I've been
patiently waiting for the Warhammer
Titan to make its appearance so I could
finally make this video the first attack
on Titan video I ever made was everytime
to explain which explained all the
different Titan types and everything we
knew about the nine Titan powers at that
time but that was back in May of 2016
and it is time for an updated version
that includes groundbreaking info about
the Warhammer Titan so here it is if you
want to see more attack on playing
videos on this channel
Warhammer smash that like button to let
me know since that's the main way you
guys can influence the kind of videos we
make on this channel if you haven't
already subscribed and hit that
notification bell so you know the
instant we upload a new video and if it
wasn't completely obvious already there
will be spoilers you have been warned
now without further ado let's do this as
we know there are nine Titan powers the
story goes that yamir fritz
the progenitor made a deal with the
devil of the earth a very mysterious
figure and attained the power of the
Titans
however Ehren Kruger says that she
gained the powers after coming into
contact with the source of all living
matter which is also mysterious the
story reminds me of when the Elric
brothers come into contact with the gate
of truth in Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood and gained the power to
perform alchemy without transmutation
circles anyways all Titans come from
yamir she possessed her Titan powers for
thirteen years before she passed on
which led to the curse of yamir since no
Titan can be more powerful than yamir
the founding titan no other type
shifter can live with the power for over
13 years after you Mir died her Titan
powers were split into nine titan powers
the founding titan the armored Titan the
colossal Titan the female Titan the
attack Titan the jaw
Titan the Beast Titan the car Titan and
of course the Warhammer Titan so we're
starting with the founding Titan also
called the coordinate it's the most
powerful of the nine Titans rod Reis
compares the possessor of the founding
Titan to God they become according to
rod the sole creator of this world and
its ultimate governing force and
all-knowing all-powerful being the
founding Titan can only be used to its
full potential by members of the Royal
fritzsche family who later renamed
themselves the Reese family when they
moved behind the walls the founding
Titan has complete control over pure
Titans and can make them follow any
order
Carl Fritz also called the first king of
the walls or the 145th King created the
three walls Maria rose and Sina using
tens of millions of colossal Titans in
recent chapters we learned that the
walls were named after the three
daughters of yamir if Willy Tiber speech
can be trusted if the possessor of the
founding Titan wanted they could unleash
all of these dormant colossal Titans to
fly in the earth however they do not
because they inherit the memories and
philosophy of King Karl Fritz who made a
vow of pacifism whether the founding
Titan has complete control over other
shifters is unclear but I would assume
that the power isn't absolute over them
since Karl Fritz could not put a stop to
the feuding between the LD and noble
houses who fought each other over
control of the remaining aid titan
powers the founding titan can also erase
and possibly even rewrite memories of LD
UNS the Ackermann clan Asian clan and
members of what Kenny Ackerman's father
calls the central houses all members of
minority bloodlines and not subjects of
yamir are immune to the memory tampering
the next power and possibly the most
interesting one is that the founding
titan allows the possessor to see the
memories of past possessors with perfect
clarity all
titin possessors have seen glimpses into
the memories of past shifters and we
learned from Gabby that if the shifters
are related
this ability works even better however
these random glimpses cannot compare to
the founding Titans ability to recall on
command memories from past possessors
this is extremely exciting because we're
talking about being able to recall all
of you mere Fritz's memories if she was
in fact a real person and not just a
story known possession of the founding
titan include yamir Fritz Carl Fritz the
father of rod Reese Yuri Reese Frieda
Reese and Grisha Jaeger who stole it
from the royal family and pass it on to
the current holder Eren Jaeger Eren
since he is not of royal blood does not
have full access to their power but this
might be a benefit since he is also not
controlled by the first Kings ideology
Eren despite not being of royal blood
has been able to use the power of the
founding Titan when he came into contact
with Deena Fritz is tightened the
smiling Titan if you want to learn more
about Deena Fritz and her royal lineage
check out my smiling Titan explained
video when Aaron comes at the contact
with the Titan he is able to command
pure Titans and make them attack Ryder
and Beth told historia since she has
royal blood may be the key to Aaron
unlocking more founding Titan abilities
we shall see but the fact that Aaron
might remember the memories of yamir
Fritz at some point really excites me so
let me break the fourth wall for a
second and ask for your participation as
we go on keep in mind which Titan power
you would choose if you could pick one
and why make sure let me know in the
comments I'm sure you'll all go with the
car Titan but I'll let you know my
answer at the end of the video ok so
next up we have the armored Titan the
armored Titans of special ability is as
the name suggests armored it appears
that all or at least most Titans have
the potential to learn to harden parts
of their skin we've seen this in the
female Titan attack tagging after air
and drink from the armored vile JA titan
beasts Titan and most recently the
Warhammer Titan who seems to have a
helmet of hardened skin however the
armored Titan specializes in armor and
constantly has armor plates on its body
although
it can remove certain plates to increase
speed at the cost of the fence the
armored Titan is considered to have the
strongest defense and as a result it was
used as a symbol for Marla's unstoppable
power however during the battle for it
Slava anti-titan artillery did
devastating damage to the armored Titan
despite its strong armor showing Marlay
and the world that technology is quickly
catching up to and even surpassing titan
powers and that Marlay is no longer
invincible like it once was along with
serving as an incredible defense the
armour like plates of skin can also
increase the armor titans attacks making
his punches much deadlier the armored
Titan is also the only Titan that has
been shown capable of handling the
colossal Titans explosion ability
without suffering serious damage
the only holder that we know of is Rider
brought however he gained the power
around the age of 10 and he is 21 after
the time-skip
so his 13 years are almost up and gabi
his cousin is expected to inherit it
from him but falco who cares for her
deeply and doesn't want her to shorten
her life is working hard to impress
Marlay so that they'll let him inherit
the power instead of Gabi if you want to
know more about Reiner and the armored
Titan check out my Reiner and the
armored Titan explained video where I
literally talk about Reiner for almost
30 minutes that's for the die-hard
Reiner fans but yeah rather than telling
you guys to check out other videos from
here on out if any topic or character
piques your interest and you want to
learn more just check out the first
playlist on our Channel and you'll most
likely be able to find a video
explaining that exact topic in much
greater detail next up we have what has
been called the god of destruction
referred to as the colossal Titan in the
anime and the Colossus Titan in the
manga this Titan stands at 60 meters
tall four times the height of the
armored and attack Titan who stand at 50
meters tall the colossal Titan is the
second tallest Titan seen in the manga
only Rod Reese's abnormal Titan was
bigger at 120 meters but he was so big
he couldn't even stand up
on his own as one would expect the
colossal tines enormous size makes the
Titan extraordinarily powerful in the
official guidebook the colossal Titan
scored and off the charts 11 out of 10
in power the colossal Titan is strong
enough to destroy the walls gate with a
single kick because the Titan is so big
the Titan body burns up quicker and
releases more steam than any other Titan
shifter although other titans release
steam the colossal Titan is the only one
that we've seen who uses the steam for
both attack and defense the steam can
blow away and burn even skilled users of
vertical maneuvering gear since the
flesh of the colossal Titan is burning
off at an incredible rate it is useless
to try to attach maneuvering gear to the
Titan but Armin is able to attach the
gear to the colossal Titan speed however
the hot steam almost kills him probably
one of the most devastating abilities of
the colossal Titan is its ability to
create massive explosions that destroy
anyone or anything in its vicinity as
mentioned earlier only the armored Titan
can withstand this blast which is why
these two titan powers make such a good
team
unlike other titans the colossal titans
body can completely evaporate in an
instant allowing the user to quickly
escape under the cover of steam although
this Titan has amazing abilities it also
has a drawback it is the slowest of the
nine Titans the former user of this tine
power was battled Hoover and the current
user is Armin are lured we haven't seen
Armand's colossal Titan in action yet
but I think he might be even deadlier
than Bennett alts version battles
personality kept him from making the
most of the colossal Titans power as the
instructor of 104 Training Corps Keith
sadhas pointed out battle doesn't take
action on his own and a soldier needs to
be able to think on his feet and respond
to the unexpected
however Armin has consistently proven to
be one of the best characters at
thinking on his feet in fact the
official guidebook has a whole two pages
dedicated to our man's amazing ability
for strategies and making quick
judgments and that's only within the
first nine volumes while battle
statistics in the guidebook are not very
impressive arm is only real weakness is
combat and the colossal Titan power
should more than make up for that
shortcoming
more if Armen does end up having royal
blood as many have speculated he'll have
even more enhanced abilities let me know
if you're as psyched to see colossal
Armand as I am now let's turn to the
female Titan in the manga the female
Titan is described by the male military
as an all-purpose unit capable in every
field her stamina is extremely
impressive when the Marlon Warriors
meaning Annie Marcell Reiner and
Berthold first arrive on the island of
parody's Annie and Marcel who at that
point possess the jaw Titan are supposed
to take turns carrying the Warriors on
their Titan forms until they reach the
gate of the wall Maria
however Marcel gets devoured along the
way and Annie has to carry Reiner and
Bennett old virtually the whole way by
herself and she succeeds in doing so
furthermore she is able to run alongside
the horses of the survey Corps find a
number of difficult opponents in pine
forest
he was vertical maneuvering gear in
human form to kill skilled soldiers and
turn into a Titan for a second time and
escape successfully it is also pointed
out in the manga that in addition to
high mobility and endurance the Titans
hardening abilities combined with a nice
striking makes for an incredible
destructive force the Selective
hardening ability can also be used to
guard vital spots of the Titans body
like the nape and to climb the walls
although many Titans have demonstrated
hardening abilities amy is the only
person we've seen with the ability to
form a seemingly indestructible crystal
around her human body the female Titan
is also able to summon pure Titans who
are within hearing range of her like all
Titans the female Titan has incredible
regenerative power but Amy's Titan could
also use selective regeneration in order
to drastically speed up the regeneration
of one specific body part this is seen
when she catches the Special Operations
squad off-guard by using the ability to
regenerate one eye extremely quickly
however this may speak more to any
skills as a shifter than it does to the
female Titan specific powers annie is
the current holder and the only person
we know of that held the power of the
female type many of you have asked in
the past if a male titanate Amy could a
man in
Herot the power of the female Titan I'll
just said you guys debate that in the
comment section but I really do hope
that we get to see Annie make a
reappearance in the manga soon next up
we have the attack tighten when Aaron
Krueger passed on the attack tightened
to Grisha he told him that no matter the
age this Titan has always moved ahead
seeking freedom it has fought on for
freedom it's name is the attack Titan
other than that the attack Titan is
still shot at in a lot of mystery which
makes sense since it's in the possession
of our main character and the mangaka
isayama may be waiting to reveal its
special ability in an epic fashion it's
possible that Aaron has just not
unlocked or awakened the special ability
yet or perhaps he did during the time
skip and we will see it soon however
it's also possible that the secret power
has already been hinted at many of you
guys were asking me about the berserk
mode or rage mode we saw an episode 25
attack on Titan the anime and what it
could mean
after Annie's Titan defeats eren's Titan
Aaron's Titans eyes take on a blue glow
and his Titan body seems to be on fire
aaron has fiery lines that resemble lava
glowing across his Titans face and body
at this point
Aaron appears to be acting unconsciously
and his will to destroy all Titans seems
to be the only thing that's keeping him
going some people will say ignore this
people will say that this is not in the
manga they only added it in the anime to
make it more interesting for the season
finale now these people are right this
is anime only in the manga Aaron is
conscious the whole time there is no
moment of rage Andy the feet sim starts
to run away up the wall because uh cuts
her down and aaron uses his titan to pin
andy's tightened down while they extract
annie from the Titans body completely
different eren's Titan never changes its
physical appearance or starts running on
all fours it is possible that this
change was just made to make the anime
more interesting but it's a pretty huge
change to make in my opinion ISA Amma
has said in an interview before that he
is involved in parts of
the anime making process and he presents
suggestions to the directors and writers
when he wishes he would have done things
differently in certain parts of the
manga so that they change it for the
anime version what if this was one of
those parts
perhaps isla Hama wanted them to add the
berserk mode and we'll see it in the
manga at some point in the future where
it will be better explained perhaps Erik
Kreuger's words were hinting at
disability as well when he said this
Titan has always moved ahead seeking
freedom it has fought on for freedom
perhaps always moving ahead and fighting
on hints at this unconscious state that
eren yeager achieves so that even if the
holder of the Titan goes unconscious
this ability will activate and keep the
attack Titan going sort of like Aang's
Abbot our state in the last airbender
this isn't certain but it would make
sense to me since otherwise this seems
like too big of a Liberty for the
writers of the anime to take especially
if that kind of power or transformation
will never appear again it seems like it
would just be a senseless loose end
unless issa yama told them that this
kind of berserk mode will appear in the
future it's just a possibility but i'd
like to know what you guys think in the
comments below
is berserk mode a preview of the attack
time special ability or is it just an
example of anime creators exercising
their creative license there was also
the instance where Ehren Kruger
mentioned Mikasa and Armin to Grisha
even though they weren't even born yet
could another possible ability of the
attack Titan be that while other Titans
could get glimpses into the memories of
past holders the attack time can see
forward into the future as well perhaps
that is possible for all Titan shifters
but as of now we've only seen a
possessor of the attack Titan seemingly
accessed future memories lastly after
drinking from rods vial labelled armor
Eren like many other shifters learns how
to harden in his Titan form he can
harden specific parts of his body like
his fists however unlike other Titans
we've seen he can also hurt in his hole
Titan body and it will stay that way
even after Aaron exits the Titans flesh
this is the way he plugs the hole in
wall Maria during to return to shegaon
sheena arc any
as we know eren yeager is the current
holder of the attack titan and he got
the power from his father Grisha Jaeger
who got an intern from air and Krueger
no other past possessors have been
revealed at this time then there's a jaw
tighten as the name suggests this 5
meter class Titan has an insanely
powerful jaw Marlay official said that
the jaw Titan is an assault unit it's
small size makes it the swiftest of all
it's powerful nails and jaws can crush
just about anything even if the Titans
frame is smaller and weaker than most
it's precisely its small size which
gives this Titan the huge advantage in
certain terrains like in the titan
forest where the chimpanzees like titan
can maneuver better than anyone else the
jaw Titan is especially good at quick
attacks that escaping from other Titans
but can be easily overpowered in a
prolonged fight with other Titans as
we've seen when Ymir's titan tried to
protect the members of the hundred
fourth Training Corps at would guard
castle the current possessor of the jaw
tightness Porco Galliard who got the
power from yamir who in turn got the
power from Porco's brother Marcel it is
interesting that you Mears jaw Titan
looks strikingly different in appearance
from Porco's JA titan Porco's version of
the jaw Titan also had hardened skin on
its face and nails while you Mears did
not next up we have the Beast Titan this
17 meter class Titan has a very unique
appearance it is covered in hair like an
ape and it has extremely long arms the
Marlin military is very impressed by the
beast eins throwing abilities the beast
line can throw objects like boulders
with great force and accuracy from an
impressive distance like many other
shifters Zeke has revealed that he can
harden his skin he tried to do it in his
epic battle against Levi but he failed
because Levi moved too quickly in
contrast to past beasts Titan holders
Zeek Jaeger most likely due to his royal
blood can control pure Titans that were
created by him Zeke can turn audience
into Titans with a roar and he doesn't
even need to transform into the Titan
form to do it as long as the LD ins have
been previously injected with his final
fluid
unlike the founding Titan his control
over these Titans is not perfect and
they occasionally disobey his orders
perhaps because of his impressive
intelligence after
all he scored and off-the-charts 11 out
of 10 in the guidebook Zeke can speak
fluently while in his Titan form most
Titan shifters cannot speak in their
Titan forms at all but yamir and her jaw
Titan form peak in her car Titan form
and also the Warhammer Titan are capable
of some intelligible speech so as
mentioned Zeke Yeager Aaron's
half-brother is the current possessor of
the beast Titan power and we do not know
the identity of any past possessors
however we do know that Colt Grice is
expected to inherit the be sign power
from Zeke although he would not have
access to all of Zeke's abilities since
as far as we know he is not a royal
blood now we get to the Titan power that
I'm sure everyone wants the cart Titan
now yes that was sarcasm because the car
Titan has got a lot of hate in the
comments section of other videos but as
you'll see it does have some very
impressive abilities
according to marlane the car Titan with
its unusually high endurance is well
suited to long missions this allows them
to equip it with armaments expanding the
variety of tactics at their disposal the
endurance of this time form is second to
none we looked at how impressive the
endurance of the female Titan is but
it's nothing compared to the car titans
the car Titan is also known as the
quadruple Titan since it uniquely
travels on all fours peak can maintain
her form for at least two months so long
that she forgets how to walk on two legs
when she turns back into her human form
and has to readjust the quadruped Atal
form also makes this Titan one of the
fastest like the jaw Titan this is what
allows the car Titan to save Zeke and
Reiner and escape successfully in the
return to shegaon Sheena Ark as
mentioned Peake is also capable of
intelligible speech in this form she
seems to be pretty fluent along with the
warhammer tighten and Zeke's beast Titan
peak is the current possessor and we do
not have information on any past
possessors side note peak is quickly
becoming one of my favorite characters
although I don't think she'll ever
surpass Mikasa and finally we've arrived
at the Warhammer Titan oh how we've been
collectively way
for the identity and the powers of the
night Titan to be revealed and it's
finally happened in chapter 101 this
Titan has a really cool design inspired
by Kanye West himself the hardened skin
around the head is reminiscent of a
knight's helmet the unique ability of
this Titan to mention Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood again seems to be
similar to Ed's alchemy in that it can
materialize weapons either out of
surrounding material or perhaps out of
thin air it uses a kind of long
Warhammer that greatly increases its
reach also it seems that when the Titans
Warhammer makes contact with the ground
it can manipulate the earth and create
spikes that can penetrate the opponent
either one large spike or many smaller
spikes this is what we've seen so far
and it makes sense that the Warhammer
Titan has the ability to create weapons
since in the historical images we saw of
the Warhammer Titan we saw that the
Titan also held a hammer and it's not
like there are a lot of massive hammers
just hanging around waiting for a Titan
to pick them up I definitely think this
is one of the coolest powers we've seen
so far and we have a lot more to learn
about it the Warhammer Titan was able to
defeat Eren in attack Titan form even
after the time-skip
so it is very strong although we are not
100% certain if Aaron was giving it his
all we're just testing the power of the
Warhammer Titan since he knew that
Mikasa had his back I am curious to find
out about its weaknesses since at this
point its powers seem pretty insane this
Titan is currently in the possession of
Lili Tiber sister who appears to be
quite skilled at using its powers and
that's it for this video guys like I
said I've been waiting to make this one
for awhile and I'm so glad I could
finally make it for you guys
now that we know all nine Titan powers
let me know which one you would choose
if you could and why I believe that I
would still want the founding Titan
power because I love the idea of being
able to control tens of millions of
colossal Titans modify memories and just
have access to unimaginable amounts of
knowledge however in this hypothetical
situation I would have to have royal
blood and be immune from the 145th Kings
I
ideology my second choice though would
be the Warhammer Titan at this point
since I think it's abilities are pretty
amazing anyways thanks so much for
watching guys drop a hashtag Warhammer
hype if you made it this far and
Warhammer smash that like button if you
enjoyed this video I definitely enjoyed
making it for you guys if you haven't
already subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you know the second
a new vid is out and if you just can't
wait until the next video
follow us on Instagram for daily anime
posts including attack on Titan and
conversations until next time see you
space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]